hugo mois chaque été je passe ton était
à mykonos est ce que tu
[Rires]
es qu'est ce qui se passe là-bas à
biganos oui abbassen plage fait d'accord
un peu d'alcool dès l'enfance
samia beaucoup dans la vie des femmes et
hommes comme un bon ami ne vient pas non
mykonos et ma semaine avec mes amis
[Rires]
tu sais que tu tousses au 18 juillet il
m'a fait bouffer
mais c'est donc on n'est pas ensemble on
se retrouve le 19 août
ils étaient ensemble une semaine avec
ses amis une semaine à scheider ça c'est
une très bonne
série
si je m'éclate non mais ça donne un ton
ni s'éclater est-ce que ça s'emporte
également
tout le corps entier
maintenant je suis en couple
donc tu fais une semaine tu t'éclates
hugo mais rien non rien les places ne
pas baiser pendant une semaine les fans
[Applaudissements]
ben non mais attends c'est ce qui même
pas un petit mot
c'est quoi un petit fou qui frotte bien
du tout rien même pas un petit quoi un
petit eu trois garçons sérieux
après si on danse on est en soi et des
gens qui n'en fait pas non plus jouer
donc lui jeter les gens à partir de
quand considéré s'est trompé
c'est sale affaire est ce que dieu tu me
regardes de façon dubitative ces couples
libre non mais alors rien pour toi ton
mec partir ça me coûte cher mais vous
êtes fou quoi il ya plein de couple
filles qui peuvent partir en vacances
sans leurs meilleurs mais moi j'ai
combien de doigts depuis des années à
chaque fois que j'ai une meuf et moi
aussi je vais une semaine où je suis à
moi avec mes potes
[Rires]
bien sûr elle aussi
d'accord oui mais non sera pareil c'est
les vacances inquiet mais moi voilà mais
parce que c'est beaucoup trop moi c'est
moi je ne fais rien je peux pas lui dire
moi je suis pas dans ce délire d'alcool
tout ça moi je suis français je suis et
les banques tu vas tu à royan et se
passera rien
[Applaudissements]
quand même la fin des chaux de fonds
la
bannière du risque plus de lait un peu
mieux que bouffer des radios
[Applaudissements]
tout ne peut pas résister à la tentation
non lui allah lui alors lui faut qu'il
arrive à nicolo oui c'est une idée comme
un enfant dans un magasin de jouets
tout essayé il est obligé de toucher à
tout comme un fou partout à tous les
rayons alors mais tu le lâche à mykonos
et non mais il est impossible ce n'est
sans il est impossible en mec me dirige
par seule une semaine à mykonos nord la
confiance il serait la fin non mais
c'est vrai que moi oui c'est une
question de confiance aveugle maudit je
vais partir seul à mykonos
va falloir repartir dans une seat ibiza
mais les amis et j'y vais chaque année
depuis 15 ans avec des amis des filles
des hétéros enfin c'est pas dur
pour l'instant pour l'instant la
proposition me titille
j'ai des copines elles sont fraîches tu
vas
elles sont fraîches où elles sont
fraîches à plat
non c'est pas de la 8e ni à son réveil
tu sais que toi c'est quand les dates de
moi d'eilat eh ben c'est du 3 août au 13
je serai là du 3 au 30
maintenant la somme là pour l'instant
j'aime bien la maison du beau-père de
3,2 prénom qu'ils sont et comédie alors
je peux te parler de margaux margot
lacan j'adorais la reine et au bois
j'aimerais pas la personne
d'autres prénoms est intervenante et
surtout sur margot margot
margot torti aux jeunes selon la requête
à aller voir sur instagram et la tortue
margot torti
non mais bamadou margot va très bien
sarko sera là magot sera là c'est qu'on
est dans une maison tous ensemble ouais
tout à fait une maison très sympa ici
les modalités eux
quelles sont les modalités pour faire
partie c'est bon tu peux déjà venir
cellou et c'était je ne peux y pensez
déjà
mais tu fais un seigneur
les trois ans khraishi là bas vous avez
une proposition de vermeil moitié est
vraiment dégoûté alors il va me faire sa
proposition pour l'instant c'est hugo
c'est le gogo
qui tient là bas et hugo je vous le dis
je me sens tout de suite moi les
manteaux ont pas lui c'est pas mal c'est
bon je mets une séance avant que mathieu
caisse cultura non mais je te le dis ils
pourraient non mais je pourrais comme
boire du monde
mais j'ai pas la meilleure du coup je
pourrais partir avec une cible à toi oui
et lui même et lui comme et
mykonos une semaine mais il tissera ça
se trouvait tu me verras
j'espère vous serez pas dans la même
soirée
parce que lui quand il va au rang bosser
c'est pas ça guérin
patrice qu'ils aient quelque chose à
propos alors moi j'ai entendu dire sur
ce plateau oui c'est pas si c'est vrai
mais j'aimerais bien que vous me le
confirmer oui vous avez un très beau
bateau
je n'ai pas de bateau et
donc sur votre bateau invisible ce
serait sympa de faire peut se faire un
petit tour de corps
alors c'est comme ça qu'on m'écoute
l'essence
laisse tomber je suis chez hugo emmerde
pas avec ça allez on va tout de suite
éliminer la proposition
évidemment je vous propose royan mais
sachez que quand j'arrive à royan iront
ils remettent la façade et ça s'appelle
nikon hausse
je ne savais pas les combos club
une chanson qu'on dit c'est quoi le
projet de vacances aux chambres avec vue
sur mer et avec son mamère a bien sûr
aussi quand elle dénonçait ce oui mais
voilà clp
aujourd'hui encore comme une
merde pas ta mère de patrick
chan
et le soir et puis on rentre chez soi
[Rires]
c'est la boîte à la mode la banque alors
en dessous la bonne des années 70
pour l'instant non
à cette année bon c'est pas attendez
donc pas la pala yamani je lui demande
pas ce que je devrais jamais vous avez
tort non parce que l'on ya des gens
comme ça à problèmes
ces deux personnes à problèmes sérieux
ça veut dire tu es sûr que tu vas partir
en vacances et les cultes il va
t'arriver coup tu
es tu ne sais les six ans que j'aurais
pas avec toi on te paye tout non mais tu
paye tout et on va voir que des bateaux
les bâtons et mapouna rochelle
c'est vrai que
c'est vrai quoi qu'il arrive je n'y
avais pas avec toi mais je t'aime
beaucoup sur ma paye clément alors moi
dans un tout autre genre j'ai besoin de
refaire du sport j'ai fait du tennis
pendant plusieurs années j'ai arrêté
donc si vous pouviez m'initier au paddle
pendant tout un été tout petit je vais
me faire chier
tu crois avant qu dépressif je suis déçu
amis connaissent
pas de l'ami conway ya beaucoup de
manches mais un peu de raquette
non mais non alors non je pour l'instant
je vous dis pour l'instant c'est hugo
m'a séduit mais il a dit des mots qui
sonnait
après dit marc gaubert gratuit gratuit
lundi alors moi aussi ce sera gratuit à
a alors déjà très bien mais moi aussi je
peux
même pour dimitri repas alors avec
daniel on vous embarque en sicile
j'ai peur j'ai eu très peur je me suis
alors allé donner partout où ce
sera une semaine on va dire paddle pas
mal pizza à ce qu'il joue arrière
et reviennent bien mais on auquel quand
[Rires]
est-ce qu'elle et son chant pas tes
vacances les brosser pour le de la
journée ajouté m
un petit tour en bateau autour les
éoliennes a pas d'arrêt a par exemple ah
ouais voilà il ya une jolie fille
magnifique un peu comme margaux m est
bon et je te dire mois l'international
je suis saignait beaucoup de françaises
mais c'est un contemplatif il en fut
alors géraldine j'adore toi j'irai après
d'accord
je fais la semaine avec
ya des chances
beinheim chercher des
bonbons
et l on veut faire le tout bon awards un
combo est ce que c'est quoi un combat le
combo d'abord chez hugo puisque avec
hugo c'est la chasse et la chaîne hbo
c'est mort puis après quand vous quand
vous allez dire que vous sortez du goût
mais non c'est quand même
[Applaudissements]
elles sont et son animation fiancée est
quelqu'un que j'aime énormément et
d'ailleurs je ne l'aurais je ne mange
pas de ce pain là même pas quelques
biscottes match à défaut donc fixé la
semaine avec ego et je vous récupère et
on part à florence à florence je sais
que vous êtes un intellectuel totalisé
menem ça sent le musée
on irait main dans la main dans les
musiques ne sait que sur l'arno vas voir
tu crois que je peux dire maintenant à
voir avec quoi comme ça le 17
flo en train de visiter des musées mais
tu sais quoi je rentre ici je voulais
vendre à qui tu croyais c'est magnifique
c'est de qui s'agit
martinien
je suis une meuf s'appelle florence et
puis après voilà et on se trompe se
promènerait dans les rues le trafic sera
enfin c'est chiant tu m'aimes il sait
quoi que ces vacances tracera lorsqu'on
mène dans des ruelles
jonah fou de me promener dans les
ruelles vous
dans la course sa concurrente attention
plus excitant j'organise une semaine
nature et découvertes à la grande motte
avec les meilleurs zen
l'aura de l'activité ressourçante et
relaxante tels que le pédalo
l'accrobranche mais aussi le beauf h de
cul
alors mal c'est dans le prospectus ses
clients
d'accord
non mais j'ai certainement la senteur
chan
[Rires]
n'est pas un cottage
allez allez à propos de l'arrivée alors
déjà j'ai beaucoup aimé aller kubo
haegeli vous a pas fait rêver
lui le nom mais
beaucoup trop
dommage devrait il ya des choses après
avec ses vaches et un prévenu c'est sûr
mais croyez vraiment que j'allais en
vacances et que j'ai bien ri mais sans
déconner c'est durable
[Musique]
il n'y avait pas toi
ça va cd oui les
précédents rappelle olivier rousteing de
chez balmain j'adore j'adore l'idée il
me dit j'ai loué la plus belle maison
nikon hausse un bateau de 25 mètres
vient avec qui tu veux je dis pourquoi
pas nous naim dit je l'adorent là bas il
ya son coach sportif et surtout deux
mannequins féminins
qui fait défiler dans ses amis chez qui
seront sur place
[Applaudissements]
la barre elle à tomber par à mykonos on
a le crous teint on est là
tout
ça peut être du
mythe ou c'est mon pote j'ai passé deux
ans de la corse avec lui des arts je
peux te le dire et il t'aime beaucoup
moi aussi j'adore ça marche je le pense
a
les plus belles plages ou knight easing
c'est gratuit
tout est payé il a loué la maison vous
êtes sûre même comme vous l'avez dit
hanouna qui vient ni bien avec ton
meilleur ami je lui dis mais pourquoi
pas luna il m'a dit [ __ ] je t'adore
deux mannequins féminins alors que la
peau jaune pour toile de 23 ans sont
magnifiques
[Applaudissements]
alors franchement je suis pas du tout
être pas position dans quoi c'est le
génial je le dis je le dis j'aime
beaucoup ta proposition
tu fais moitié-moitié c'est à côté
malheureusement je nique de couilles
[Applaudissements]
à
la salle de sport et pour le remercier
de tout cette année je te paye
l'aller-retour non à la
[Applaudissements]
manua ça va très loin ouais mais en
transavia
juste pour mettre un petit peu de piment
ouais vous m'avez parlé de mannequins de
bateaux de villas de maisons de est ce
que pour mettre un petit peu de piment
on a vite fait pas d'être
pour l'exotisme
il faut demander aux joueurs par leur
vivier
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est parce qu elle peut décider
pour moi le pire
j'ai serré la dore en boîte de nuit m'a
dit mais qu'est ce que la dernière
semaine celle là dormi je l'aï je
l'adoré amoureux
devant l'instance h et ouais je voudrais
avant les dates d'abord c'est que les
dates ah oui ça je peux demander olivier
dans la mine non mais c'est quoi c'est
plutôt juillet s'est plutôt fait toutes
les deux comme j mc lean je m'incline il
ou non ne vous inclinez pour ne vous a
pas demandé
du coup prosterne devant mathieu en quoi
ces deux convaincants moi j'ai dû du 3
au nom de 13,16 pas mal ça je le sens
bien je sais pas pourquoi ouais c
confirmant dans quoi j'ai peur que avec
toi ça s'apprend cacahuètes
des malades quoi bah oui je veux qui se
passe
sans parvenir à rebours et
je ne dois pas et les top models ça vous
dit
de xavi je vais rester célibataire
pendant deux ans ben ouais ouais mais ça
a commencé quand
la maison tous les soirs alors les
mannequins oui c'est
champagne c'est génial je bois pas on
s'en fout vie un peu à nous je vis je
vibre thème est ce que tu te propose
même état usa les approprient entre la
jet set je sais le match et tout est la
simplicité mais on va jouer aux cartes
ce soir ou
voilà des choses parfois simple séquence
et mac os
signature
[Applaudissements]
si l'audi crois que me faire chier à
jouer au bridge juste
c'est bon comme ça m'a mis non mais je
vais voir mais les deux c'est bien mais
c'est jean chez l'un trois jours chez
l'homme il faut pas se partager un peu
bas je vois tu vas revenir tu seras
comme nous
vega se dit alors que chez nice intégrer
la phase du projet devrait par contre
bien que des meubles la barre à gauche
avec toi
[Applaudissements]
tu vas tu as tourné ouais on est déjà je
suis bêtement comme un caprice mais va
tenir deux jours à faire des ou non et
des ringards là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme ça
les connaît même et
non mais t'inquiète pas on est ensemble
et après je le dis je passerai trois
jours avec l'un d'entre vous un ouais
ouais je passerai trojan avec daniel
[Applaudissements]
en désintox
[Rires]
mais c'est vrai voyons avec sa mère
à avoir des petites grenadine
[Rires]
diabolo grenadine
tentant de dire qu'on a
là ah c'est bien ça me fait plaisir de
savoir vous allez passer vacances mais
c'est vrai qu'on voit tout de suite les
vagues dans les personnalités ces fonds
elle c'est l'amérique aveux des
bateaux télé tu es là les rigolos mario
tama généreuse moi je vous invite oui
boileau l'asticot boulot aussi
voilà dire a dit c'était pas mal où ça
va c'est pas mal ça me ressemblait pas
mal certain que rien ouais j'ai raté pas
mal fait peut-être trois répète deux
mois trois jours trois heures
gmt que ça fait ça